- La nouvelle plage de l'est
cherche son identité,
mais on sait déjà
ce qu'elle ne sera pas.
CAROLINE BOURGEOIS,
mairesse de Rivière-des-Prairies
- Je l'ai dit ici, là :
C'est pas le Beachclub
Pointe-Calumet là.
(musique techno)
- Pas de foule en transe
à prévoir dans ce secteur
du bout de l'île.
Mais pas de baignade non plus.
- C'est sûr que j'aimerais ça,
mais c'est pas grave.
- Partout, des panneaux
indiquent que le sol,
sous l'eau, est contaminé.
- C'est une contamination qui a
été faite à cause de la marina.
- Sylvie Bibeau fait partie
de ceux qui portent ce projet
de plage depuis plus de 15 ans,
quand la marina Beaudoin
a fermé. À quand une eau
baignable selon elle?
SYLVIE BIBEAU,
Comité ZIP Jacques-Cartier
- Pour moi, le délai
de deux ans est raisonnable,
à moins qu'on trouve
des artéfacts. Là,
ça peut être un peu plus long.
- Ce ne serait pas le premier
retard dans le projet.
Car, en 2013, on disait déjà :
- (journaliste):
La plage devrait
être prête l'été prochain,
après des dépenses
de 1,4 millions $.
- Finalement, elle a coûté
pour l'instant près
de 9 millions. Et 5 millions
supplémentaires sont budgétés
pour la décontamination.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- On n'a peut-être pas accès
à l'eau, mais il y a quand même
des jeux d'eau, il y a
du volleyball de plage,
on peut louer des embarcations.
- Comme ces kayaks, simples
ou doubles, qui seront
disponibles dès vendredi.
MARILOU ST-PIERRE, coordo.,
Route de Champlain
- Il y a plein de parcours
avec les guides, on peut aussi
informer les gens qui viennent
avec leurs propres embarcations
sur les trajets qui sont
intéressants, puis les lieux
où ils peuvent s'arrêter.
- Une grande jetée en bois
permet aussi de surplomber
le fleuve, en face de l'île
Sainte-Thérèse.
Quant à la navette fluviale
qui reprend du service
entre Pointe-aux-Trembles
et le Vieux Port,
elle s'arrête un peu plus
de 2 kilomètres en amont
de la plage.
Et si vous vous demandez
pourquoi ce n'est pas une plage
de sable blanc, eh bien,
c'est parce que le sable
risquerait d'être englouti
totalement par le fleuve
en cas d'inondation,
contrairement aux petits
cailloux, qui ont l'avantage
de rappeler la plage
de Nice à Valérie Plante.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, M